covid19 hit this boxing school with a
million pound loss
when thailand's foreign tourists dried
up so
too did the money
but now the island of phuket has a plan
to tempt
back vaccinated holidaymakers
staff here can't wait it's like a new
life for them you know they have been
staying home for the last two years but
now
i think they're back to work again
back to their regular life again
the race is now on to jab 70 of the
island
by july the first then vaccinated
tourists can visit without
quarantine
they can't leave the island for two
weeks but can travel around it
hopefully bringing life back to the
deserted streets
the reopening gave us hope to get back
to life once again
and we don't expect a huge demand at the
beginning
before covid bays like this would have
been packed with
boats but many people's incomes just
stopped overnight
and the hope is with the re-opening of
phuket
thailand is taking its first tentative
steps towards restarting
mass tourism on company
it can't come soon enough businesses are
shuttered
day trippers from phuket helped keep
this whole
island afloat
[Music]
as people here wait for foreign tourists
to return
local businesses are donating
how will you know if the phuket
reopening plan has worked when i can
stop giving out life bags like this
phuket's grand reopening cannot afford
to fail
siobhan robbins sky news phuket thailand